resta il ragazzo giu domenica siamo su
un episodio di afp
siamo al 154 sono sbaglia roba che
proprio non esiste nel mondo impossibile
andiamo a vedere i livelli di oggi
quello che meritino almeno quello da
vinci tech demo
partiamo subito con da vinci così viva
l'italia questo spesso si sa questa è la
madonna questo carro armato di da vinci
però quello dentro non mi sembra proprio
leonardo da vinci vengo in pace solo che
non sono capaci a farla la pace salve di
nuovo non hodgkin a terra leonardo da
vinci so che nel tempo è diventato
vecchio leonardo da chuck dunque se
guardate c'è una netta somiglianza tra
noi lo rado da vinci album dolce master
proviamo a vedere sul suo largo un dojo
quanto me la cavo io faccio sempre
cagare sugli appunto oggi ma oggi però
serata buona è andata benissimo in
realtà però va bene ti prego no
bravissimo buono buono
madonna no ragazzi non ci ha promesso
fare una partita così prendi lo per
l'amor di dio ha posto
iniziamo nell'episodio colombelli
prossimo ragazzi mi mancavano in questi
che sono un po è un impulsivo
effettivamente se io devo passare
pubblicamente lì in mezzo lo sai vero
madonna che tattica non ci vuole anche
pensato di fare così
perché questi italiani non ovest i
livelli che non è impossibile un altra
roba però la be rock swing
ti stiamo facendo tutti oggi sono ha
scatenato c'è chi sta facendo alpino
colpo tutti quanti cosa succede
ragazzino devono rompere questo primato
tutti al primo corpo attenzione tutti
non rompere questo primato è di ti prego
maledetto vedi che come parlo delle cose
io ne devo parlare delle cose ma porco
demonio veri che se stavo zitto va
aggrappati buono bravissimo finale
essendo vado non sa neanche cosa
però va bene però va bene sono figlio no
stai tranquillo zio sono più pigro io
non ho mai fatto un livello di aps c
gioco da dieci anni
venite da veri ambulances match
attenzione di testa madonna solo per
cava bene fretta vorrebbe caro di testa
per adesso solo attirarmi alla fine
mancavano da ben distinta buono dovrei
anche a farlo teoricamente prendi lo
prendi la ma perché c'è un'ambulanza
vicino ring e qualcuno spiega la bagarre
mediocre ma non poche 1999 spesso si è
imposto con mike era un poco jam con un
po del milan
baker devo arrivare ad hacker è l'unico
modo per arrivarci e andare sulla
piattaforma questa sinistra in marino
buono però devi starci sopra colpo lo
zio bravissimo a chi ha fatto chuck
norris goku odio e sopra goku siam
sicuri no perché veramente io ho dei
dubbi
bellissima la strisciata bravo fratello
e manca l'ultima che la vittoria con gli
arpioni sei stato un po maledetto a
mettervi le prove dai proviamoci sono ci
riesco penitenza non la voglio fare la
penitenza per favore fai vincere io non
farò mai una figura di coda più grande
di questa sua è più il rock swing faccia
non è uno normale per comunque la
penitenza darà un bacino a pietro ve lo
giuro che lo farò vedere nelle storie di
instagram
spero il più tardi possibile per ora ma
galan se riesco a finisci tutto su pezzi
sto cannone amen
ecco a posto non si sta facendo più
difficili rho quindi perché e sacrifici
anche apparse le robe perché diventa un
menomato prima maledizione per il casco
le braccia adulti guarda guarda quanti
diventato semplice erano rock swing
difficilissimo
sono vivo no non è vero
e vabbè ragazzi dai vi prego fatemi fare
un livello normale oggi è veramente così
difficile non prenderti le cose oh mio
dio quanto tempo per fare questa cosa
che ha un ora
bene finalmente sono fiero di me
possiamo adattarci questo messo due ore
per farlo finché non era così difficile
verso boltro era non potevo le facevo
dire ma non era emerso attraverso dire
che ho già vinto a reverse cui risultati
la vittoria e la morte la volta di
storia ecco perché questa è veramente
difficile perché io sono sempre bravo a
beccare lewin quindi il fatto solo che
mi hai messo al contrario per me è
difficile perché rischio l'inizio
all'aver ogni caso il pezzo che finisce
nella vittoria unito però non è successo
a quanto pare non aspetta che la
possibilità o no però vinto babbo natale
va bene deve andare sud est smorte porco
schifo è così difficile ragazzi beccare
la vittoria in un altro non è mai stato
così difficile ma no mi ha coperto la
morte era l'unica roba che potesse
aiutarmi
[Musica]
amen e stato molto difficile cercare la
sconfitta non sono bravo a fare questa
loggia sta purtroppo una cosa pochi
semplice michael chi è michael tu sei
michael mag i ragazzi ho trovato un modo
per schivare la morte che non è niente
male
guarda che roba adesso vorrei decano
sbloccato la villa vittoria tensione
michael aiutavi dammi la forza ti prego
[Musica]
grazie ai golden gate dovrei sap mi
porta alla vittoria mi ha portato la
vittoria con kate non dovevo non devo
lasciare le mani se non mi porta via la
vittoria ma non vorrei fare
semplicemente cadere sulla vittoria però
grazie molto gentile table tavolo a è
una di quelle che leggo i tavoli ok
senza al tavolo però però una moneta
l'ho presa sono molto bravo il successo
tv che quello che penso
madonna vabbè che gol bellissimo l'ho
fatto guarda come un castrato da far
male non ho toccato con le mani quindi
questo è un gol che vale tutti gli
effetti ma che gol
bellissimo riproviamoci ragazzi perché
vuoi provare un altro tiro un po più
bello sudiro ne presento salve signor
portiere io la amo
senti col portieri portano nei golden e
tra la palla 1 gliela sperma donna che
testata con una testata così muovi
probabilmente salve ho donato è stata un
bambino gli spiace ma teoricamente amo
il mio pubblico per quello che sono
dovrò darmi una scala cade parata ma lo
sai che separa la palla non è vittoria
vero io dovrebbe spiegare al caso visto
il gioco ha messo le vittorie a caso
madonna ci credo non ci credo
ti prego noto la di no di una parata
retorico io mi spingo dentro mi spingo
perché questo merita di entrare a è
fortissimo sto portiere non passa nulla
buffon è grande e bellissima miglior gol
non è mano è per carità non l'avete
visto male voi siete voi che non
guardate bene guardate meglio l'ultimo
livello ragazzo oggi faccio un buon
trovo per finire una roba molto molto
classica ma voglio finire col purtroppo
che vi sono andati bene quindi secondo
me potrei fare di meglio attenzione
primo controllo della storia fatto con
una vittoria le allora non so perché non
faccio schifo che purtroppo molto in
musica o la parco lemonia c'è una morte
sono due cene sono possibile che pero
sembra quelle halloween per cortesia dai
non è difficile ai chakra vittoria
limits ma quella non la puoi prendere
vita non puoi far canestro lì
[Musica]
porca vacca ciò pure creduto è rimasto
sull'aiuto va bene e ho messo tutte le
palle nel finale quindi niente ragazzi
questo è veramente difficile
attenzione buona
la vittoria ma non puoi prendere la vita
regola sopra imposti parte che ci passa
attraverso secondo te bene poi sbloccato
aiuto don't move endesa e mi fai
rimanere qua all aiuto mi ha tolto solo
una morte però io prenderò proprio
l'ultras commenti anticipate non l'ho
presa però preso mio figlio ma porca
vacca ma così difficile sto livello alla
figlia devo lanciarti sulla vittoria
spodesta la farà ancora una palla va
bene
no ragazzi non sono uscito neanche a
sbloccare la vittoria una volta buono ce
l'ho fatta adesso ti prego vittoria ti
prego no no non me lo tocca a me non fa
niente buon umore
meno male ciao ragazzi più ore per posso
livello incredibile bellissimo però
signori questo è per oggi sono contento
ho fatto un gol stratosferico spero che
valga il video lasciate un bel mi piace
ci vediamo il prossimo episodio di e
finiscono nei livelli più speciali
perché fosse bisogno sono quelli degli
speciali quindi preparatevi schiacciate
il tasto mi piace che vedete qui sotto
il tasso iscriviti e la campanellina che
è sempre vostra amica e schiacciata la
campanella fa un bel suono provate ci
stavo scoprire se è vero o meno e ci
vediamo a un profondo bei ragazzi
[Musica]